et avec nous ytreham bonjour Yves merci
d'être avec nous le directeur adjoint de
la rédaction du Figaro et le politologue
Olivier merci d'être là Mathias nous a
rejoint on va parler de la réponse de
l'exécutif après une semaine des meute
le signal d'écoute envoyé par Emmanuel
Macron au maire victime d'agression ou
de dégradation il en a reçu plus de 200
à l'Elysée hier leur promettant
notamment des réponses pour accélérer la
reconstruction et puis le signal de
fermeté envoyé par Elisabeth borne la
première ministre promet elle des
réponses pénales fermes et s'en prend à
l'attitude de la France insoumise lors
du champ républicain et dure
rassemblement national on va parler de
tous ces sujets pendant cette demi-heure
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron a donc reçu hier à
l'Élysée plus de 200 mères touchés par
les émeutes parmi eux Christophe
Rouillon bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes mère socialiste de
Coulaines dans la Sarthe vice-président
de l'Association des maires de France
d'abord avant de parler de cette
rencontre Emmanuel Macron disait
recevait les maires victimes de ses
émeutes d'agressions de dégradation
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans votre
commune Christophe Rouillon
et bien dans la nuit de vendredi et
samedi nous avons connu des émeutes
extrêmement graves alors que nous sommes
une ville très calme habituellement mais
si nous avons sommes une ville de
banlieue avec 50% de logements sociaux
et dans cette nuit bien nous avons eu
une attaque par une trentaine des
métiers de à la fois de la ville avec
des feux de poubelles avec des voitures
brûlées et puis le plus grave c'était
l'attaque de l'hôtel de ville et
l'incendie de l'hôtel de ville par trois
individus
voilà qui qui se met à nez moi
considérable dans la ville et puis qui a
mis notre voilà notre hôtel de ville à
l'arrêt pendant plusieurs jours
dans votre commune on ne pouvait pas
imaginer une chose pareille même si
j'avais toujours craint cette situation
parce que vous savez nous les élus nous
sommes pas bunkérisés
nos hôtels de ville ne sont pas entourés
de grillage et ne sont pas gardés donc
voilà il y a une espèce de
tabou de protection puis l'hôtel de
ville c'est le lieu de tous les coûts
c'est là où il reçoit les services donc
voilà c'est une espèce de profanation
d'un lieu symbolique de la République et
c'est ça qui a créé vraiment une très
très grande émotion
alors on va parler de votre rencontre
hier avec Emmanuel Macron vous étiez
reçus avec plus de 200 mères sur le fond
sur la forme qu'est-ce que vous avez
retenu de cet échange avec le président
de la République
d'abord sur la forme le président de la
République a pris le soin de nous
écouter la rencontre a duré près de 4h30
4h30 4h d'intervention des maires et
puis 30 minutes de conclusion par le
Président de la République donc c'était
déjà un symbole fort il a exprimé le
soutien de la nation Omer attaqué on en
avait besoin dans ce contexte parce
qu'on a vécu des autres très difficiles
avec nos équipes donc sur la sur la
forme il m'a semblé que c'était assez
opportable de nous réunir dans ces
conditions
et sur le fond le Président vous a
écouté quatre heures vous l'avez dit
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
a compris vos inquiétudes et qu'il y a
répondu surtout
je pense qu'il a compris nos inquiétudes
il les partage parce que c'est l'État
qui a été attaqué globalement après nous
avons eu des mesures concrètes proposées
à savoir la création d'un fond d'urgence
pour pour reconstruire nos bâtiments
détruits avec des procédures allégées
une loi d'exception sur particulière des
procédures de marché public et également
d'urbanisme s'ils engagements par
rapport au commerçants victimes
également aussi à fond pour pour réparer
les caméras de vidéosurveillance donc ça
c'était des mesures plutôt attendues y
compris aussi un point important c'est
celui de la réglementation de l'usage et
puis aussi de la vente des mortiers qui
servent à impressionner les les
populations et ça n'a pas commencé avec
neige c'était déjà avant on sentait déjà
une pression d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui veulent le chaos dans nos
villes ce sont des nouvelles plutôt
ça veut dire que sur la reconstruction
est-ce que le chef de l'État s'est
engagé auprès de vous à ce que ce soit
l'état qui paye les dégâts qui ont lieu
dans vos communes alors bien entendu les
assurances seront appelées parce qu'on
n'a pas payé des cotisations pour rien
mais dans le cas où les assurances
n'iraient pas jusqu'au bout même si la
pression apparemment sur les assurance
sera forte l'État s'est engagé en tout
cas ce que l'on puisse reconstruire les
outils et ça c'est important d'assurer
si la continuité des services publics et
d'ailleurs nous à Coulaines nous avons
réouvert dans un autre site les services
aux habitants parce qu'il faut montrer
que ceux qui veulent nous attaquer nous
détruire non pas gagner après sur plus
globalement il y a eu il annonçait cinq
chantiers et là nous attendons de voir
parce que nous avons des propositions
qui qui sont globales sur la question de
la décentralisation sur la question
aussi d'allègement des procédures en
particulier de petit de la ville pour
consommer plus facilement les crédits
sur la question de la restauration de
l'autorité également
dans les écoles les mesures par rapport
aux familles là on a le logement
également là on a des engagements plus
vastes et qui ne sont pas non plus
chiffrées parce que président de la
République a dit dès le départ qui
n'aurait pas de de grands plans
financiers supplémentaires et là ça nous
inquiète un peu parce que bien entendu
c'est tout à fait souhaitable à la fois
de fixer une perspective une trajectoire
de ne pas non plus son bruit dans la
démagogie en particulier par rapport à
la sanction des familles parce qu'il ne
faut pas non plus tomber de l'autre côté
de la barrière j'allais dire et puis ne
pas non plus aggraver le mal mais nous
n'avons pas eu d'annonce d'un plan
massif alors peut-être que le Président
de la République a peur de l'annoncer
après ces destructions mais on risque
d'être entravé en particulier dans les
opérations de rénovation urbaine qui
vont prendre de qui nécessite toujours
des moyens et puis vous savez dans les
banlieues il n'y a pas que des voyous
casseurs il y a 99% de gens qui vivent
et qui ont besoin que on leur donne des
services auxquels ils ont droit dans des
quartiers très pauvres et encore dégradé
agresser Gérald Darmanin a parlé de 13
évidemment on a eu le cas très médiatisé
de Vincent Jean Brun le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses est-ce que vous auriez
souhaité que le chef de l'État annonce
de nouvelles mesures de protection
envers les élus
assurer son soutien très fort et la
protection de la République mais il n'y
a pas eu de mesures concrètes et c'est
vrai que il y a une inquiétude parce que
oui le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses à
barricadé sa mairie peut-être de façon
peut-être un peu exagérée mais résultat
ça s'est retourné contre contre lui donc
là il y a eu d'autres mères qui ont
d'ailleurs été attaquées et nous avons
besoin de ce point de vue là de mesurer
exceptionnelles de protection il faut
protéger les maires parce qu'ils sont
vraiment le dernier rempart de la
République et puis je souhaite aussi
qu'il puisse y avoir aussi une
reconnaissance de nation par rapport à
l'exercice du mandat de maire sur la
protection juridique sur les conditions
d'exercice du mandat sur la possibilité
aussi d'avoir des meilleurs indemnités
pour permettre à des gens qui sont dans
la force de l'âge qui ont envie de
s'engager de pouvoir faire face et là
nous n'avons pas eu de mesure et nous
reviendrons avec l'Association des
Maires et aussi l'association des
petites villes de France que je
défendais parce que les émeutes ne sont
pas produits que dans les grandes villes
également dans les petites villes de
potirons à mettre la pression parce que
sommaire sans él u sans adjoint il y
aura plus de Républic et c'est ça qui
était interdit attaqué aussi par une
poignée de par quelques individus par
quelques amitiés au-delà de la question
sociale qui se pose et ça il faut
absolument continuer à le défendre
fermement
merci Christophe Houillon merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité maire
socialiste de Coulaines dans la Sarthe
et vous faisiez partie des mers qui
était donc reçu hier par Emmanuel Macron
merci d'être venu nous parler de cette
rencontre il serait on l'a entendu dans
ce que nous a raconté Christophe
frouillon 4h le chef de l'État a passé
4h à écouter les maires c'est un peu le
retour du grand débat finalement merde
de France oui à chaque fois il nous fait
ça il est il est très disaire notre chef
de l'État il aime bien et dissertation
il aime bien les les je dirais les
exercices oratoires bon c'était
utile de toute manière quoi qu'il arrive
parce que faut faire aussi de la
calinothérapie dans ces instants là pour
montrer effectivement aux élus locaux
que ils sont ils sont pas lâchés par la
République et ils sont pas lâchés par
l'État je crois que bon c'est ça après
il faut on peut discuter de savoir
est-ce qu'il fallait un nouveau plan ou
pas moi je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent qu'il en fallait pas que c'était
ridicule
en plus d'agir comme ça sur le coup
c'est c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas souhaitable vous savez on dit
souvent que le Président de la
République et le maître des horloges
tout démontre depuis le début de son
quinquennat qu'il n'est pas le maître
des horloges précisément que toute lui
impossible toute l'actualité qui émaille
ces deux mandats lui est imposé il n'a
jamais voulu les gilets jaunes il n'a
jamais voulu la crise sanitaire les
retraites il pensait pas que ça serait
aussi compliqué il n'a jamais voulu
l'explosion d'explosion
c'est raté donc à chaque fois si vous
voulez il est
l'actualité lui impose son agenda alors
est-ce que il faut prendre des mesures
ici ou là pour protéger les mers pour
moi je crois qu'il y a une chose qui n'a
pas été dite pour ce qui concerne les
élus locaux et la raison pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui les maires qui sont
d'ordinaire les élus les plus appréciés
de la population c'est vrai qu'il y a
une déconsidération des élus sauf de mer
qui est le maire de l'élude proximité
d'abord il faut voir que les maires qui
ont été agressés ou les villes dans
lesquelles il y a eu des explosions
c'est beaucoup de mineurs qui ont causé
tout ça les séminaires eux ils ne votent
pas ils en ont rien à faire du maire
première chose deuxième chose je crois
que ces mers sont en train de payer ceux
qui ont été
bousculés dans leur organisation ils
sont en train de payer d'une certaine
façon ce qu'ils font pour lutter contre
le trafic de drogue et c'est le trafic
de drogue qui a été désorganisé dans
beaucoup de communes c'est une des
raisons de ce qui s'est passé à
L'Haÿ-les-Roses ou le maire était
vraiment en première ligne là-dessus et
bien les trafiquants et les petits
dealers ce sont rebeller contre ça donc
faut pas non plus si vous voulez
théoriser trop
sur la misère sociale sur le mal-être il
y a des causes qui sont des causes
cachées
oui mais je pense que il est important
de parler des trafics et d'abord du
trafic de drogue qui qui peut gagner
certains microcarctiques et pas
seulement dans les plus grandes villes
donc ça c'est un facteur qu'il faut
évoquer mais ceci dit on va pas non plus
rayer d'un trade plume la fracture
territoriale et sociale qui était déjà
visible d'ailleurs y compris dans les
villes moyennes et petites et qui là
nous renvoie à des dimensions de
pauvreté de sous-éducation de
désœuvrement à 30% des 15 29 ans ne sont
ni en emploi ni en formation ni en étude
dans certains quartiers alors
les deux sont corrélés c'est-à-dire que
les économies parallèles se s'installent
dans des quartiers qui
parfois des micros au quartier dans des
qui sont en déshérence et heureusement
il y a que les petites villes et les
villes moyennes étaient touchées par ses
émeutes oui mais je remarquons que
depuis 2014 la politique dite de la
ville s'applique aussi à ces quartiers
c'est à dire que l'État a quand même vu
les choses et c'est à partir de ce
moment-là qu'on met en place un
ministère à l'égalité des territoires et
désormais une agence très bien
simplement donc heureusement qu'il y a
des politiques publiques qui visent ces
quartiers ont fait le constat qu'elles
sont insuffisantes mais ne renversons
pas si vous voulez les choses parce que
il y a une tentation qui est de dire
tout ça fonctionne pas donc supprimant
ou ne finançons plus ou moins
là ce sera alors pour le coup tout à
fait délétère donc
plan banlieue ou pas
appelons ça comme on veut politique de
la ville ou changeons le nom s'il le
faut mais l'abandon du plan Borlo ça a
eu des conséquences ce qui à mon avis
devrait quand même susciter de
légitimité et embarquer les mers
durablement au-delà d'une réunion parce
que c'est l'affaire quand même c'est pas
de leur dire comment l'a dit déjà
d'ailleurs en 2019 oh là là les mers
sont merveilleux le couple mère préférée
quelque chose de central à vous pouvez
le dire toute la journée mais il faut
qu'on appelle ça un plan ou une
politique ou pas il faut des axes il
faut des axes financés et clarifier
parce que la politique de la ville
aujourd'hui et depuis quelques années le
problème c'est que vous avez des tas de
mécanismes de financement des tas de
programmes et qui a un manque de
lisibilité et puis dernier point on
parle beaucoup des maires mais par
exemple le porteur de la politique de la
ville ce sont les intercommunalités
alors on parle plutôt on devrait plutôt
parler pour l'efficaces de blocs
communales
ayant présent à l'esprit des communautés
d'agglo de communes les métropoles là
dessus
oui bien sûr bien sûr alors le plan
Borlo
évidemment et puis derrière ça il y
avait beaucoup de politiques il y avait
une espèce de rancoeur de la manière
dont on a été une erreur
après à mise en scène son sa mise à sa
mise à l'écart enfin tout ça il y avait
beaucoup de de non-dits là-dedans
alors le plan Borlo qui était quand même
il faut le dire une espèce de catalogue
aussi qui était qui partait un peu dans
tous les sens
faut pas oublier que
il a été en partie exécuté ce plan Borlo
parce que comme vous l'avez justement
dit c'est pas parce que le plan Borlo
n'a pas été adopté
solennellement dans sa globalité que des
actions n'ont pas été conduites il y a
des actions qui ont été conduites et la
politique de la ville elle n'a jamais
cessé depuis depuis 50 ans elle a
toujours existé cette politique de la
ville alors après il faut savoir si elle
est efficace si elle est si elle va au
bon endroit si elle tape juste c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut considérer mais je
crois que
il faut aussi
arrêter d'être trop je dirais trop dans
la complaisance de de ce qui se passe et
il faut quand même à un moment ou un
autre et c'est le ton qui est donné
aujourd'hui je trouve de la fermeté je
trouve que et le président de la
République et ministre de l'Intérieur et
la première ministre et le ministre de
la Justice on fait preuve de fermeté à
l'exception du premier jour quand le
président de la République à mon avis a
fait une petite erreur en parlant de euh
de de ce policier il s'est il s'est un
peu à mon avis
un peu vous nous faites la transition un
peu c'était un peu hâtif c'était un pote
vous êtes parfait puisqu'on va parler
justement de la fermeté Mathias hier le
mot d'ordre du gouvernement c'était
fermé à l'égard des émeutiers Elisabeth
borne a rappelé quand l'espace de 7
jours les forces de l'ordre procédé
après de 3000 interpellations que le
Garde des Sceaux a transmis une
circulaire de politique pénale au
parquet leur demandant une réponse
rapide ferme et systématique résultat
des peines lourdes et exemplaires déjà
plus de 350 personnes placées en
détention dont certaines avec mandat de
dépôt et encore plusieurs centaines de
garde à vue qui pour certaines
pourraient amener à des déferlements
devant le parquet Oriane et le matin
même Elizabeth borne elle avait appelé à
la fermeté politique face à la France
insoumise ouais c'est un carton rouge
qui est assez Élisabeth borne à la
France insoumise devant les députés de
sa majorité la première ministre est
revenue sur ses échanges depuis lundi
avec les présidents des différents
groupes parlementaires et parmi les
attitudes pointées du la salle de
Mathilde panneaux à la tête du groupe la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
la députée du Val-de-Marne a notamment
quitté avant la fin la réunion à
Matignon moi je suis très choqué par les
propos de la France insoumise qui
refusent de condamner des violences qui
fait le tri dans les bâtiments qu'on ne
pourrait pas attaquer ce qui veut dire
que d'autres pourraient être attaqués je
pense que c'est une preuve
supplémentaire que la France insoumise
ne se positionne pas dans le champ
républicain
il y a aussi un deuxième round c'était
cette fois dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée voilà ces attaques de la
part de la première ministre ne pouvait
pas rester sans réponse de la France
insoumise hier après-midi il y avait une
séance de questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement au Palais Bourbon et la
première intervention et bien était pour
Mathilde panot
que connaît le pays n'ont rien à voir
avec la mort de Naël pire vous voulez
faire peser sur nous la responsabilité
de la colère le retour au calme ne se
déc
se construit des mairies et des écoles
sont incendiées des magasins pillés des
élus et leurs familles attaquées et vous
vous cherchez des coupables partout dans
toutes nos institutions républicaines
sauf chez les auteurs de violence la
majorité présidentielle continue là sa
stratégie de cornériser la France
insoumise en prenant le soin de la
distinguer des autres composantes de la
nuque comme lors de la réforme des
retraites souvenez-vous avec les
milliers d'amendements qui avaient été
qui avaient empêché l'examen de
l'article 7 du texte ouais Olivier c'est
une c'est une bonne stratégie politique
ce que fait Elisabeth borne qui a
sonnait vivement prise à la France
insoumise c'est la stratégie mais bon la
France insoumise se prête bien au jeu on
pourrait dire là depuis le début il est
vrai que
sur la question de l'arc républicain
aujourd'hui le message envoyé par par le
gouvernement et pas qu'aujourd'hui
depuis un moment et plus de en quelque
sorte de pointé LFI que le rassemblement
national dont la stratégie et somme
toute validées d'intégration aux
institutions en tout cas en apparence
bon donc on voit bien qu'il y a il faut
dire que la question sociale se pose
plus sur le devant de la scène depuis le
début de ce quinquennat que d'autres
donc et puis à l'intérêt évidemment de
fracturer l'anus puisque l'idée est de
et surtout pour Elisabeth borne et de
d'ouvrir un peu je dirais cette
coalition du centre dont on parlait
Jean-Pierre Raffarin et pour Élysée à
bedborne plutôt d'essayer de détacher
éventuellement dans la durée des
éléments venus encore de la gauche alors
qu'on voit bien le pas trop
mais il va y avoir des érections et on
sait que la nuque c'est assez divisé
donc voilà
c'est une stratégie de harcèlement pour
l'opinion publique je ne suis pas sûr
puisque la question est-ce que c'est la
bonne stratégie je suis pas sûr que pour
l'opinion publique tout ceci soit très
intéressant et très valorisé c'est à
dire que la confiance dans la vie
politique et dans le personnel politique
ne risque pas de d'augmenter avec ce
type de
diatribble oui non c'est sûr c'est que
alors le rassemblement national c'est
difficile de dire quoi que ce soit parce
qu'il dit rien précisément enfin Marine
Le Pen ne dirait ne dit pas grand chose
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit elle
cherche à
se faire à se faire discrète à montrer
que c'est pas elle qui est la source de
la tension parce que c'est ça aussi que
il est il est montré c'est qu'en fait la
France insoumise a fait le pari et
surtout un discours qui consiste à dire
la violence d'État c'est la violence
illégitime et notre violence c'est la
violence des de ceux qui cassent est une
violence légitime y compris d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui se s'opposent au bassines
enfin toutes les projets qui peuvent
être écologiquement contestables et bien
ils sont en train d'essayer de renverser
la charge de la preuve c'est là que il
se situe et c'est pour ça qu'on dit qui
se plessitue hors de l'axe de l'arc
républicain qu'il conteste en cela ils
ont un projet qui est un projet
révolutionnaire c'est à dire qu'ils
veulent faire tomber le régime et ils
veulent faire tomber les principes sur
lesquels ce régime repose c'est
dangereux c'est très très dangereux
parce qu'ils estiment que là ils ont une
clientèle qui est une clientèle pas
nécessairement électorale mais enfin bon
ils l'ont prouvé quand même puisque ils
ont regagné quand même beaucoup de
couleurs justement dans les banlieues
des grandes métropoles c'est le c'est le
pari qu'ils font en face le gouvernement
c'est un jeu bah évidemment très
dangereux le gouvernement
pour l'équilibre du pays j'entends et
enfin ce que le gouvernement l'a compris
ça il l'a bien compris c'est pour ça que
le gouvernement plus ça va plus il a un
discours de fermeté face à cette à cette
contestation qui n'est pas loin d'être
une rébellion
par une radicalité idéologique je ne
suis pas sûr que elle est fille veuille
une révolution et les personnes qui ont
voté pour les filles dans les banlieues
ceux qui se déplacent sont aujourd'hui
victimes de ce qui se passe dans les
quartiers et de ce point de vue la
parole portée par qui n'est pas
d'ailleurs totalement consensuel au sein
des filles si j'ai bien compris qui est
porté par certains élus de la fille
pourra être mal comprises aussi par
certains électeurs de ce parti au
législatives donc je nuancerai un peu et
gauche sont en travail compris LSI est
en travail il y a des rapports de force
qui qui évoluent donc pour la suite
soyons prudents et je moi je me garderai
de dire que LFI veut déstabiliser l'état
parce que quelque part quand on partit
si Peugeot électorale on veut un jour
éventuellement le gouverne ça c'est pour
la stratégie politique mais sur le fond
on entend de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
et d'Elizabeth borne un discours de
fermeté retour à l'ordre républicain
c'est la priorité est-ce qu'on est un
peu dans un virage du macronisme
là-dessus
et à l'expérience mais c'est sûr que le
le reproche principal qui était fait à
Emmanuel Macron et c'est un reproche qui
était fait surtout par la droite qu'elle
soit radicale ou pas c'était d'être
faible sur le front régalien et là ben
il a l'occasion de montrer sa fermeté et
on a il y a quand même un changement de
discours assez radical je trouve de la
part du garde des sceaux le le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est pas très nouveau
depuis le début ils essayent de marquer
des points sur ce terrain là parce que
il a une ambition qui sont plus grande
que ça et puis le président de la
République il voit bien que s'il veut
continuer
garder son autorité jusqu'à la fin de
son mandat parce que lui il est pas en
position de se faire réélire il faut
impérativement qu'il se fasse qui fasse
respecter et qu'il et qu'il applique je
dirais les principes régaliens de façon
très très affirmée et donc voilà il a il
y a intérêt il y a intérêt parce que le
problème du président de la République
c'est que comme il peut pas se faire
réélire son autorité pour essayer petit
à petit et l'étirement de son autorité
viendra aussi du fait que de moins en
moins le régalien sera respecté et
surtout que ça pousse du côté de la
droite et du côté du rassemblement
national sur cette question bah écoutez
Valérie Pécresse elle était ce matin
l'invité de RTL elle demande plus de
côté vis-à-vis des mineurs délinquants
la moyenne d'âge des personnes des
centaines de personnes qui ont été
arrêtées ces 17 ans le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est que nous avons une justice des
mineurs qui n'est pas en capacité de
juger en comparaison très rapidement des
mineurs on n'est pas non plus en mesure
de les mettre hors d'état de nuire
c'est-à-dire de les enfermer dans des
endroits où ils ne peuvent plus troubler
l'ordre public de les éloigner de leur
quartier moi je pense qu'il faut leur
pourrir leurs vacances je pense que tous
ces casseurs tous ces incendiaires il
faut que on les mette hors d'état de
nuire il faut les sanctionner et
quelques minutes plus tard je regarde
Jordan Barney le président du
Rassemblement national était l'invité de
ses news et lui aussi propose plusieurs
mesures pour lutter contre la
délinquance des mineurs
nous avons un problème aujourd'hui avec
des mineurs une grande partie de ceux
qui ont cassé sont des mineurs je pense
qu'il faut des centres éducatifs fermés
pour les mineurs supprimer la majorité
l'excuse de minorité parce que bien
souvent cette excuse de minorité est
utilisée par les trafiquants drogue pour
exposer des mineurs sachant qu'il ne
risque rien et je pense qu'il faut
descendre de redressement fermées
encadrer par des militaires pour les cas
les plus récalcitrants voilà on entend
ce discours du côté des républicains du
côté du rassemblement national est-ce
que Emmanuel Macron va être contraint
d'y répondre Olivier d'abord les jeunes
ça veut rien dire c'est une extrême
minorité de cette tranche d'âge dans
certains microquartiers qui s'aiment le
désordre alors ensuite les moyens bon il
existe depuis il existe d'abord une
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse il
existe donc dans ce cadre des mesures de
suivi des éducateurs et puis des centres
ouverts et fermés il y a quand même des
dispositif qui existe et puis ensuite il
existe par exemple depuis la loi de
mémoire de 2007 des conseils de droites
et de voir aux familles qui sont pas
trop utilisés et qui sont autant là pour
cadrer les parents dans la relation à la
fin que les accompagner parce que vous
ne pouvez pas comment dire
montrer du doigt des familles
monoparentales qui vivent souvent dans
une pauvreté et en plus ne leur faire
qu'une leçon de morale et il faut les
accompagner ça veut pas dire manquer de
fermeté l'accompagnement mais voyez sans
quoi ce discours qui n'est que celui de
la sanction ne créera pas de nouvelles
légitimité vous vous devez faire sortir
aussi de d'un sentiment de pas leur
courir leurs vacances comme le dit
Valérie Pécresse bon excusez-moi mais
enfin je ne sais pas ce que cette
formule signifie ça veut dire quoi
l'État n'est pas là pour pourrir la vie
des gens il me semble
oui non c'est une expression mais c'est
une expression qui est un peu creuse
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'effectivement il
existe des dispositifs qui sont
aujourd'hui peut-être pas utiliser à
plein la révision comme on l'entend des
ordonnances de 45 parce que c'est ça qui
demande en fait quand il veut revoir
l'excuse de minorité ça fait maintes
fois qu'il en est question depuis 45
précisément il faut savoir que les
ordonnances de 45 j'ai pu le chiffre en
tête mais elles ont dû être réformés une
trentaine de fois depuis 1945 donc à
chaque fois on dit bon bah voilà ce qui
est sûr si vous voulez c'est que il faut
d'abord que ce qui existe les
législation qui existe soit appliquées
et c'est ça qui me semble très important
et très manifeste de ce que je vois là
depuis quelques quelques jours c'est que
j'ai l'impression que la magistrature
que la justice applique les enfin
sanctionne comme avec
l'arsenal quand elle dispose après il
faut avoir si cette appliqué dans les
faits mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
suivi des faits déjà vous savez on a
tendance à aller dans une incontinence
législative à chaque fois on en tasse on
crée des nouveaux dispositifs et alors
que les dispositifs existants ne sont
même pas appliqués appliquons ce qui
existe et puis après faisons le bilan et
là je pense pas que les républicains les
remettent sur la table leur idée de
supprimer les allocations pour les
parents de mineurs des enfants qui a été
posée il y a une dizaine d'années par
Eric Ciotti et qui a été expérimenté qui
a été très très mal je dirais interprété
à l'époque parce que en fait dans les
départements où ça avait été expérimenté
ça avait été suivi des faits
c'est-à-dire que les parents menacés de
se voir retirer pendant un temps ou
suspendre leur allocations familiales et
bien avec contrôlé justement leurs
enfants et du coup il y avait eu très
très peu de sanctions qui avaient été au
bout du qui avait été qui avait été
appliqué donc ça avait été efficace et
efficace
vous savez
ça avait été mal interprété notamment
par un certain discours de gauche qui
avait fait de la morale là-dessus mais
qui n'avait pas gardé la réalité de ce
qui avait été exécuté alors bon il peut
y avoir des
des menaces dissuasives ça ça peut ça
peut trouver il faut bien il faut bien
cibler la sanction la suspension les
allocations elle est pas immédiate comme
ça il y a au moins quatre ou cinq
il peut y avoir des menaces dissuasives
mais il faut aussi encore une fois
rassurer accompagner un certain nombre
de familles des orientées et puis je
pense que ce qu'il faut pourrir on l'a
dit mais je pense que c'est la vie des
trafiquants de drogue dans un certain
nombre de d'endroits et trafic tout
court d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a pas que
la drogue je pense que c'est ça ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut pourrir ensuite on
voit bien aussi que il y a à faire de
l'éducation et notamment dans l'usage
qui est fait des réseaux sociaux on peut
reprendre quand même cette thématique je
pense qu'il y a tout des programmes
éducatifs et à développer pour pour une
meilleure maîtrise je dirais
des réseaux sociaux et de l'usage qu'on
en fait y compris dans les familles
parce que ça fait longtemps maintenant
que les plus jeunes sont à la fois chez
eux et à la fois et surtout sur les
réseaux sociaux donc comment faire de
l'autorité parentale il y a pas que les
familles dans les plusieurs concerts
il faut dans tous les cas faire un
travail culturel et éducatif de fond
auprès des populations et encore une
fois pas seulement celle qui qu'on a vu
dans la rue ces jours-ci
on va bien évidemment parler de ces
sujets puisque c'est à la une de vos
quotidiens ce matin
[Musique]
et Mathias évidemment logiquement à la
une de la presse régionale ce matin la
rencontre entre le Président de la
République et les maires ben oui
plusieurs centaines de mères à l'Elysée
ça méritait au moins ça Oriane le Midi
Libre Montpellier rend titre rebâtir
vite après la casse dans les villes et
retrace les coulisses de la rencontre à
travers l’œil du maire de
Bagnols-sur-Cèze dans le Gard le Progrès
de Lyon préfère rechercher des solutions
et par le par exemple de la loi
d'urgence annoncée hier par le Président
de la République enfin le Dauphiné
Libéré s'installe dans les habits des
mers et parle des doutes qu'ils ont émis
à l'issue de la réunion notamment sur la
réponse à apporter à la crise toujours
en lien avec les émeutes les premières
condamnations tombent Mathias oui
exemple en Champagne ou l'est éclair et
Libération champagne ont suivi plusieurs
affaires au tribunal judiciaire de trois
résultats les peines tombent pour trois
des quatre prévenus 6 mois ferme avec
aménagement de peine sous forme de
bracelet électronique pour deux d'entre
eux le troisième école de six mois ferme
avec placement en détention tous
comparaissaient pour participation à un
groupement formé en vue de la
préparation de violence lors de Man sur
la voie publique on change complètement
de sujet puisque sont tombés hier les
résultats du bac enfin libéré titre
l'union de Reims La Voix du Nord préfère
retenir l'émotion malgré le peu de
surprise depuis la réforme bancaire même
chose pour l'éclair des Pyrénées qui
nous rappelle que les résultats du bac
sont toujours un grand moment d'émotion
un petit tour de table rapidement
l'année du bac la mienne oui
[Rires]
on était pas prêt à cette question
je vous donne rapidement les résultats
du coup moi 2012
au niveau national 90,8% des élèves de
la filière générale ont transformé
l'essai pour les filières technologiques
et professionnelles le taux de réussite
est de 78%, sont tous en légère recul et
on finit et ça va être le cas évidemment
plusieurs fois dans les jours à venir
par le Tour de France la Grande Boucle
Lauriane la frontière passée les
coureurs du peloton vont se frotter aux
premières grosses difficultés du
parcours la République des Pyrénées
l'annonce les voilà une étape entre pots
et larynx au programme et comme le dit
la Nouvelle République des Pyrénées à ne
pas confondre attention la fièvre monte
dans l'école et on suivra ça vous
regarderez l'étape cet aprèm évidemment
aussi avec attention on va garder vos
une en attendant elle a Une du Figaro le
très lourd bilan d'une semaine de
violence oui on fait le bilan chiffré
enfin on tente de le chiffrer sur le
plan économique notamment
alors le patron du Medef sortant je
crois en route des yeux à parler d'un
milliard d'euros mais bon c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça évidemment parce
que c'est très difficile à évaluer et
régénérer la démocratie par l'État on
regarde tout ça un petit mot vous avez
10 secondes donc c'est il y a aussi une
démonstrative de fonds de façon
ascendante peuvent refaire de la
légitimité y compris dans les banlieues
merci beaucoup Olivier Roucan merci
frère d'être venu merci Mathias bon Tour
de France merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis on pourvoir revoir cette émission
c'est sur public sena.fr prochain
rendez-vous sur notre antenne à 15h la
séance de questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement à 16h30 nous suivrez en
direct l'audition de Gérald Darmanin
devant le Sénat sur les émeutes et puis
à 18h Thomas Hulk sens public très bonne
journée à demain
[Musique]